Frankie Jonas aka the bonus Jonas cited  for possession of marijuana  [Music]  et can confirm that Nick Joe and Kevin's  16 year old younger brother was caught  with a drug by police in Nashville  Tennessee on Tuesday but a source  confirmed e.t he was not arrested unlike  his famous brothers Frankie he steers  clear of the limelight  he's got interesting in early November  Frankie went to visit Nick on set in  Hawaii the two shared this pic of n to  Instagram while on a hike the singer  wrote in the caption quote family first  et spoke with a Jumanji star last year  where he gushed over his little bro  genius very handsome  [Music]